to just do an outfit change before this
yes well what let's dive right in
you're brought a breath of fresh air
into this that was much-needed
disappointing though because we thought
you were gonna be holding a diamond oh
look I got a lot of time you don't need
a giant plastic one to hold on TV you
were that's it the thing is heavy
you know it is what it is I think when
you look at all the girls they show all
of the facets of their lives and there's
a big portion of my life that's missing
which is my home life and my family
because I think that's when you get to
see the softer side of someone and I'm
not always like so militant you mean I'm
well actually that's not true at home
that might be the worst place to see me
be militant and mean but you know I'd
get it I'm hoping next season I got a
lot of diamonds which you can always get
one more there's never enough diamonds
well how are you feeling about the
housewives ride so far I feel good I
feel weird you know I think that I was
so like like I liken myself to like a
nervous cat effort I was just I I was
just always like ready for something to
happen to me and it didn't happen and
and then we were caught and then
everything's great so you were on edge
all season long no not all season okay
but in those first beginning I was um
nervous and I relied on a lot of old
like debutante II skills to kind of get
me through and I think yeah I mean I
don't like a lot of what I saw about
myself II - okay do you still but I Know
Who I am and I know that that's not like
all there is I think that was just like
a difference mechanism
Teddy looks like she's wearing a black
romper teddy when I talked to her last
week she was saying she felt that you
maybe had watch the show and research
the women and came in with preconceived
notions everybody was I love you but I
have three children and I don't have
time to do that and I'm opening a store
like no that is the furthest from the
truth and actually it was rather a
little bit offensive to me I'm just
telling me the truth
I didn't know that this was a thing
about Teddy until we did it and as I but
you know no I didn't I didn't research I
I am only just now beginning to
understand this whole Twitter game like
I just don't know I mean that's not my
I've lived in a bubble for 17 years did
you watch the show before you signed up
for it or are you familiar with from
season two of Everly Hills there was a
woman named Dana Wilkie on the show I
did you know 25,000 honestly I did not
remember her funny show what I had heard
was that maybe she wasn't super liked so
I don't know maybe that's me now I don't
give price tags about that cause I've
seen people have been comparing you to
her but saying you're like now we have
like the new improved models oh gosh I'm
the new improved model well I like new
that's good I guess that's like you know
something we can take positive
well you mentioned like you don't get
about price tags you don't say numbers
but Rinna almost every week keeps saying
she's so rich yes so much money she's so
rich but she's read chuny she's alright
she's a
a lot of good money but how do you feel
about her saying that repeatedly does it
bug you at all or do you not care of
course I care because you know I because
I don't talk about that kind of stuff
but um no I don't care that she says it
this way she can says she can say
whatever she wants she she's bleep up
you've known her for quite some time
Garcelle has also known her for a while
and Garcelle told me that she was
surprised to see that Rena operates in
this was differently than the Rena she
knew outside of this group of friends
did you find that to be the case no you
know what I think is that we all like I
think no I think Lisa's exactly the same
it's Jenna just accelerated she's the
same person we're all the same people
just probably accelerated that's all
it's just like amped up a bit but
yourself amped
well you came in kind of amped you came
in hot I thought that Teddy maybe you
were gonna be a little boring okay I'm
sorry are we supposed to be honest or
not of course Jeff any regrets of
anything you've said so far
confessionals I don't think so no I
think that I'm definitely I am regretful
of like putting Teddy in a position that
makes her so upset
I'd like I don't I don't want to make
anybody cry don't want to make anybody
feel like they need to leave the table
um so yeah I regret that for sure but I
think she was missing that point I I
want to lift people up not put them down
I really do
well after the dinner party moment with
Teddy we see her say to Kyle she does
not want you to go to the all-in retreat
but we know you show up at the all-in
retreat so how does that go I'm glad I
went
are we on an upswing here now with Teddy
from here I don't I think then we see a
lot of this it's like a recurring
pattern with the girls on the show we
get into like little things and then we
resolve them because at the end of the
day we really are all super great girls
do I love them yes do I hate them
sometimes yes the answer is yes
who did you find to be the most genuine
the easiest to connect with personally I
connected with Kyle the Mason the
quickest there was something about her
immediately that I liked
she likes to laugh I think maybe she
gets my jokes sometimes understood but I
think she can get something I I just I
really like her
was there anyone who you felt seemed
fake in the beginning you know you know
I think people would expect me to answer
Erica but that's not the case I think I
just I got Erica immediately like we're
southern girls and we we know how to to
put our wall up but there's something
else there so I trusted her immediately
and that might be she mad who knows if
that was the right brain thought but I
think it was to read and I thought that
was the person that I was gonna have the
most in common with but you just didn't
get that bond immediately and we didn't
have a lot of time one-on-one so that
was the the challenge was to read this
season obviously everyone is kind of
waiting week to week of like when is the
Denice stuff coming when is the Denice
stuff coming
miss issue well let's see if you had
been honest I was honest no I've been on
it I'm done
Denise no God how far out are we from
getting into that well I don't know what
do you mean this okay what are you I
don't know the Denise thing is there are
so many different little earthquakes
that are happening I guess before the
big the big one and so I think it's just
it every it's always building and
there's other conflicts that happen
there's a lot more to this whole season
than just you know like Denise and
Brandi there's a lot more look I mean
you put eight women together
and eight really like kind of
narcissistic strong women together we're
gonna have some things that's just like
the nature of the game so that the
Denise thing it's one bit of it there's
more there's no link are you at all
caught up in what goes down with Denise
are you more of a spectator oh I think
I'm probably no I think we're I think we
were awful I don't know if I would call
it spectators not like leads into a
whole different scandal but I'm hoping
didn't surprise me I can't wait to see
it play out I can't wait to see like all
the facts because I don't have them I
don't think anyone has all of them right
I know I don't have the facts that's
just the truth of the matter knowing
what you do know right how do you feel
about how things shook out with Denise I
will tell you that I actually do want to
see what happened during the course of
the whole time we were all together
because we shoot separately and then
together so and when we're separate you
don't know what's going on you know you
just you don't you don't know so then
when we get together you learn some
things but then some things are said 100
you know behind closed doors so I I
gotta tell you I got a watch I'm not
making a decision with all the facts in
there can I ask though what was your
reaction during I am NOT doing this you
guys
we've got I'm stopped bravo Bravo 10
Bravo I'm out I was just confused I'm
like is it's just like a state court I
didn't understand I didn't get it is
that what we and like like cut there was
no there was none of that there wasn't
like that it I don't know we just I just
kept going hate my salad so you want to
see how that all shakes out what else
are you interested to see for the rest
of the season is there any moment you're
looking forward to or dreading forward
to every single episode I cannot wait
they really do Mike I'm on pins and
needles and I was there it was amazing
Wow we meet were crazy girls it's like
so cool and that was happy to be a part
of it what surprised you about the
overall experience we can just talk
about the makeup situation I was really
surprised that you have to wear a lot of
makeup I'm feeling so but no I mean I
was surprised that I've made really good
friends then I think I'll have for a
long time on the makeup thing I remember
you telling me last fall that you are
not a Botox person not a filler person
not a plastic surgery person well after
seeing yourself on TV you're like baby
that's different
no I mean Mike is the botched doctor
around appointment yes I am ready all
right no changed and I still haven't
done Botox but we're getting there we're
getting there
[Music]